c'est une foule inhabituelle qui se
pressaient ce matin au cgr d2 lyon
la raison d'une telle affluence la voilà
le dernier épisode de star wars est
sorti aujourd'hui en france l'heure de
la délivrance pour de nombreux fans qui
se sont rués dès 10h sur la première
séance oui j'attends quand même
l'épisode avec impatience là j'attends
des amis qui doit nous rejoindre ce film
à tous posé un congé exprès donc voilà
on lit quand même mettre à l'épreuve dès
le premier jour sur sur le film quoi ce
qui nous donne tellement envie d'avancer
que je ne sais pas ce que je veux
récemment enfin avec tous les films qui
sortent actuellement avec une bande
annonce on sait ce qu'on va voir
est ce lui mais ils ont été très bons
dans leur la façon de novembre on ne
sait pas ce qu'on va voir
la guerre des étoiles un phénomène
transgénérationnel dont le dernier volet
promet de rapporter gros ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que le nombre de pré vente
témoignent d'une attente énorme faut
savoir qu'il ya eu trois cent mille
billets vendus en france avant
aujourd'hui donc voilà on est très
optimistes et on espère vraiment que le
film deviendra un des plus gros succès
de l'année à coup sûr et peut-être même
de ces dernières années
maison au sortir de la salle les tout
premiers spectateurs avaient l'air
conquis
alors verdict messieurs dames a pas mal
super oui c'est meilleur des 7 vallées
meilleur s est pas loin pour une
introduction c'est pas mal a dit surtout
qu'à n'ont pas déçu très loin de la
piste routière il n'y a pas spécialement
d'originalité dans le film s'est fait
des reprises des mêmes séquences qu'on a
déjà vu c'est comme si c'était un peu un
remake mais avec des avec des nouveaux
acteurs en fait un mur joue on nous
rejoue la scène en fait donc toujours
est il que les salles tourangelle
continue de se remplir de fans de la
première heure comme de jedi en devenir